- Salut! Comment ça va?
sur le plateau de "District 31",
car après six ans de travail
intense, techniciens
et comédiens ont développé une
complicité quasi fusionnelle.
CYNTHIA WU-MAHEUX,
comédienne "District 31"
- C'est du bon monde, euh...
Hé, je me fais avoir, là!
VINCENT-GUILLAUME OTIS,
comédien "District 31"
- C'est ça qui va me rendre
le plus... Et là... j'en parle,
un peu émotif.
- Stéphane, c'est ne, c'est ça?
- Oui.
- Nadine.
- Depuen septembre 2016,
"District 31" est devenue
une quotidienne culte au Québec.
Quatre soir par semaine, la
série policière était un rendez-
et un maet un maet un maet un m.
MICHEL CHARETTE,
comédien "District 31"
- On ressort de là grandi.
acteur. J'ai changé physiquement
aussi beaucoup. Je suis allé
dans des zones auxquelles
j'étais pas habitué d'aller.
en comédie, mais là, j'ai été
appelé par le drame dans cettete
quotidienne-là. Et tu sais, je
veux dire, jusqu'à date, c'est
vraiment le rôle
- Près 3000 comédiens et 6000
figurants ont travaillé dans
le "District 31". Luc Dionne
et Fabienne Larouche ont été
de réels complices dans
FABIENNE LAROUCHE,
productrice "District 31"ict 31"
- C'est sûr que ça a été... une
grande aventure dans nos vies,
de producteurs, avec Luc,les aÇs
de... grand plaisir. Et pas
toujours dans des conditions
LUC DIONNE,
scénariste "Distri- C'est intene
ici et... Non, si j'ai un coup
de barre, je me souviens de
décor-là, je l'ai fait, tu sais,
je l'ai dessiné sur un papier.
on rentrait ici.
- La dernière saison
de "District 31" se termine
au sommet, avec un auditoire
moyen de près de
de part de marché. Il y a
un sentiment du devoir accompli.
je suis rendu au moment
où je suis juste serein
et j'ai l'impression de vivre
une épiphanie. Alors, je suis
triste que ça se termine,
ça se terminer aussi,
dans le sens que j'ai bien...
tourne, ça tourne! Action!
- En cette dernière journée
age, le commandant
Chiasson nous rassure : la
grande finale sera inoubliable.,
comédien "District 31"
des larmes, il y a
du sang, il y a des "guns", il y
a des rires, comme dans toutes
(rires)- Aprè- Aprè- Aprè- Aprè,
le 720e et dernier épisodede "Dé
le 21 avril sur ICI Télé.
Il y aura le même soir deux
en coulisses le 24 avril.
(déclic d'appareil photo)
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Mon